When Donald Trump ran for President
he promised to institute a 100 day action plan to make America great again.
As the 100 day mark approaches, how is he
doing?
Reason presents the 3 worst and the 3 best achievements
of President Trump's first 100 days.
Bing bing bing!
We will be able to immediately repeal and replace Obamacare.
Along with his pledge to build a wall on the
southern border
and deport illegal immigrants en masse,
Trump's campaign was all about ramming
through the Repeal and Replace Obamacare Act,
which would have cut red tape, gotten rid
of the individual mandate
and created a true marketplace for medical insurance.
Instead, thanks to the President's own lack
of savvy and GOP dithering,
it didn't even get a proper vote in congress.
Bing bing bing!
President Trump has just ordered a military
strike on Syria.
The one action for which President Trump has
received bipartisan praise
was the bombing of a Syrian government airbase
to protest the alleged use of chemical weapons by the Assad regime.
Even opposition leaders such as Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer
signed onto a starkly humanitarian intervention
that served no greater purpose than rallying voters here in America.
Bing bing bing!
The President has issued two executive decrees
calling for a moratorium on travel from several majority Muslim countries
and the suspension of America's refugee program.
Both have been stayed by federal courts
and it remains unclear if either will ever become the law of the land.
We only want to admit those into our country
who will support our country.
Regardless, it's anti-American to effectively
establish a religious test
for travelers and migrants here.
And it also undermines attempts to reach out
to the vast majority of Muslims
who are the primary targets of Islamic fundamentalism.
Bing bing bing!
Judge Neil Goresuch.
The nomination of an intellectually powerful
and highly respected jurist
to replace the late Antonin Scalia on the supreme court
demonstrated that President Trump isn't the flake that many critics figured him to be.
So was that a surprise? was it?
Neil Goresuch might not be Libertarian,
but he is in the estimation of Georgetown Law's Randy Barnett:
'a serious thinker who believes
that government power is and should be limited.'
Bing bing bing!
There's no question that Trump has picked
some terrible cabinet members.
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has openly
talked about ramping up the war on pot
in states where it's legal, for instance.
Good people don't smoke marijuana.
He also defends asset forfeiture abuse
and has hinted at reviving federal porn prosecutions as well.
But picks such as Ajit Pai at the Federal
Communications Commission,
Scott Gottlieb at the Food and Drug Administration
and Scott Pruitt at the Environmental Protection Agency,
are serious deregulators who are already starting
to prune back regulations
that accomplish little but cost taxpayers and innovators lots of time, money and resources.
Bing bing bing!
Every new President enters office thinking
he can direct the course of human history
via his pen, or in the case of Trump, his twitter
feed.
For all his bluster and lack of self awareness,
Trump is also learning that the world is more complicated than he reckoned.
He's pushed back deadlines for all sorts of
projects,
from funding for his stupid and useless immigration wall
to a timeline for tax reform,
which shoes that he's at least living in the real world.
To the extent he realizes that his best path
forward is in cutting economic regulations
rather than vilifying immigrants, renegotiating
trade deals and starting new wars,
he'll not only be a better President, he'll create a
better America too.
For Reason, I'm Nick Gillespie.